all right so the next series of photos
you're going to have to identify which
rapper that is all right go ahead
so let's go i'm so nervous i'm sweating
on my nose
okay that's shock g
humpty dumpty wow
from digital underground yes and they're
from the oakland
right and a lot more than i thought yeah
they're from oakland and then they're
also uh
who did he give rise to he gave rise to
tupac shakur dupont they were hanging
out and tupac gave him an opportunity to
sing out one of their shows in fact
i'm going to give you more i got even
more details you get bonus points so
chucky died shout out to you guys a
couple years ago nope last year last
year and he died because you're saying
all right so shock g okay die he lived
in tampa florida he although he was from
oakland he now resided in tampa florida
right i don't know anything i'm going to
say so shock g right um
when tupac he gave him his ride so he
knew him as a kid but when tupac changed
because when tupac got shot
at the first time the first no he got
shot a bunch of times right he got shot
i think three real times right but the
second time he got shot
was shot shot was in um
was in new york and he was going up to
biggie's studio right and one of
biggie's boys came down to get him and
there was just blood everywhere right so
tupac in his mind right thought that
boogie biggie set him up right which in
my opinion he didn't
right it was just some random robbery
it's that's just my opinion
um if i was gonna between the east coast
and west coast war that went on back
then obviously i would side with the
west coast because that's who i am i'm g
in that way i mean and i was raised with
you know nwa and everything i'm a gene
that way right you weren't raised with
anything
don't be rude so anyway when shang ji
right but when that happened he lost
touch with dupont because it broke his
heart because tupac started changing and
there was a duality about tupac right
there was this his mom was in um the
black panthers right so he has this
protest
quality bright man probably one of the
brightest guys smaller than everyone in
the room
one of the best lyricists in the game
but he had a duality to him but the the
but the anger and the hostility and that
side of them became more prevalent and
which broke shock g's heart right and
then so that's that so wow all right
next one i'll say yeah you can get bonus
points if you can actually do the hook
of no no just stop stop hulk of humpty
humpty dance no no no
do the humpty dance do the hump the
humpty dance i don't know what the song
is don't make me sing but like here's
the thing yeah
next one so no wait wait bucko changes
what happened what's up man
buckle's changing a little bit
all right i get to change a little bit
man what's up okay okay good
okay i'm i'm [ __ ] light now man well my
thing is
you said again
okay
did you say okay who is this bobby okay
that's the notorious b.i.g
is that not i'll give you one more shot
stay away stay west coast stay west
coast it was a tricky photo yeah it was
a tricky photo can you choose a better
photo no but but this is the album cover
of the song
is that e30
go 10 more points north
10 more points babe 40 what
e40 let's go baby
all right first of all [ __ ] you because
that's a terrible photo but yeah does
that look like piggy he looks like a
cross between nas and biggie there
that's e40 he's from oakland
he's from oakland as well or e40 right
and his style was um very bizarre
it was different very fast very fast the
first three hours
no the first three albums
the first three albums he put out didn't
get any traction yeah it's in this
fourth album that hit okay finish the
sentence i don't know any of the music
because i'm just literally reading about
this hipper then uh
hippo hippopotamus
get up in your head like a hippopotamus
yo this is kind of fire yeah yeah yeah
yeah
hippopotamus hippopotamus all right go
ahead
all right uh here's the next one
mc light
[Music]
what do you know about her though that
was my bad yo what's up her name is
right there no kalila where's he almost
didn't yeah you said something yeah yeah
no i oh your name is up there
he didn't know he said why would you put
a photo with a [ __ ] name on there
he'd even see it okay
but he does know yeah i know mc light of
course awesome yeah go ahead next
picture okay
wow okay that's suge knight can i tell
more yeah please do all right so that's
suge knight um he's the owner of death
row records
um
he's the one that i mean obviously snoop
dre was a part of his um label but
snoop goes to him and goes
yo man
i i'll just do a regular book he goes
hey man um
that's what i don't know
hey man um snoop here
you're perfect right and he goes
uh we should can you bail out tupac and
then sign him to death row
right so
shook bailed him out and signed him and
that's
and also suge knight
was also
a
record label owner
who um
was closely affiliated and affiliated
with the crips
and it was way too close because you
know
when you're when people are around you
are all real gang members it was just
kind of i think find it to be cool
because it's like scary you know what i
mean but and also if you're going to rap
about gangster rap and that's it it
makes it more authentic
but i don't know if he's a great guy
i don't know him personally i don't know
if he's the greatest guy but that's just
my yeah okay next yeah do i get to go
deeper because i feel like i'm answering
some [ __ ] you are you are going let's
keep going
i think you should start a podcast yeah
what's uh
the history of hip hop
[Music]
i know him too give him a second let's
see if he can get the
see 12 casey 12 um oh you're close yeah
yeah okay
12 kr s krs one krs one
i knew it was i know i knew it was no
but when i say casey 12
i knew it was that's
that was his brother cousin his second
cousin
um i personally knew casey 11.
but um no he is uh
so check out him kind of
so he um
how was he discovered
he wasn't
oh yeah so what he did was i forgot who
the guy was i said i don't know the name
but
there was he
went to this club right i forgot what
the club was called but he knew that if
they played
his record on the club that they would
play it on the radio the next day and he
just kind of bombarded this guy and
because he was rejected by all the
labels and stuff like that you couldn't
get a [ __ ] going but then once that
happened you know
that's that's vaguely is that enough or
i don't know much
let's move on let's move on but you got
it right yeah i think it was a good one
i don't know you helped me here's a good
song too
the police
all right here we go
it's way before my time
think 80s babe yeah i know
uh
i don't know
new york i know i know new york
obviously look at the [ __ ] building
in the back i'm like uh san diego yeah
yeah cancun uh that's not la jolla um
i don't know
wait think about it somewhere you know
you know i know i know i just can't tell
about the glasses and stuff give him a
number let's give him a number
okay
three words to the name and
and all the first letters are the same
let all the first letter of each word is
the same
can you give me the letter
just give me the letter give him f
five
five freddie let's go
change that voice
[Music]
yeah
yeah yeah what's up dog all right
oh we know this one yeah that's uh nice
yes
there we go here we go grandmaster flash
all right
killing this you don't even need me yeah
okay any of them okay we go everybody
said this digital underground yep and
then last one
oh this is pre-surgery that's a little
kim yeah there we go she looks so
different obviously let me tell a little
kim though i can tell you about little
kim little kim was um
which is a street kid who just was
living around where um
biggie was living and
even when biggie wasn't who he was i
don't even think he was even um
doing rhymes at the at that point he
would just is even as a younger kid he
would put her little kim in a headlock
and call a little one you know i mean
just around town and um
she just hung out a lot with queen now
yeah she was
after queen latifah and money love and
stuff like that but money love
yeah yeah yeah um but
when they gave her the chance
and then p diddy was a what the [ __ ]
yeah i mean because what p diddy said
was when he first heard her he goes oh
she raps just like biggie but also
harder
and harsher right it's like and also at
the time
what else because even if you see her
perform live
little kim yeah
if you see the audience they're all male
like a lot of males and you can tell
them they just didn't want to give it up
but she kept committing to it
and that's what i love about her and
then once her first album came out it
was over she was
a household name
i'm serious about you starting a podcast
called the history of hip-hop with urban
bob and you're sort of like the middle
person
like it's you explaining
the history of hip-hop with fresh eyes
because you didn't discover this until
you're 50. until now until yeah until
last week yeah and i feel like you're a
new man no no but let me say this though
i'm not dumb
[Music]
you know i mean and i'm not mentally
challenged right so i'm i know i know i
knew as much hip-hop as some midwestern
mother in you know in ohio right i mean
some that should be your co-host
i mean that was like my so i know vague
things like i think a midwestmaster
midwestern mother would know that there
was a rivalry between biggie and tupac
right yeah of course my mom knew that
right so my point is is that here's how
i found out about it
years ago i used to hang out in venice
okay
and i used to walk down the boardwalk
and smoke cigarettes right
at cool
and um i went to a store there and they
had all these [ __ ] tupac shirts
right i knew who tupac was
um i always thought that he had a great
body
tupac right did he not have a great boss
watch any of his movies like poetic
justice
i refused i still refuse
um
[Laughter]
but i went
yo man
why don't you have biggie up there and
he goes well don't you know man right
this is back in the day in the 90s late
90s right
and he
schooled me on it
right and so that's how i knew
but that i don't know the music i don't
know you know now i know
california
i know that right yeah but you know
that's death row baby all day every day
i'm west coast for life well
i am because when the
also [ __ ] you guys
[ __ ] ah y'all [ __ ] all y'all
dog about the halftime show at the super
bowl that [ __ ] was lit dog
that [ __ ] was that [ __ ] gave me goose
goose dung
all over my body bro
dude when that came out bro right
it was like
if obviously if the super bowl was
played in dayton ohio that would make no
sense but it's in l.a and i just felt
like what a great representation of la i
thought the weakest part was 50 cent for
sure
he's a little puffy too so it was weird
yeah the upside down thing was i think
it looked like he was struggling real
hard yeah i think the upside down thing
was a bad choice
and i think that i know that you're
saying you guys are saying that that's
what he probably chose to do well no
that's what it was based on the music
video i know but i think that he showed
up and some talent coroner was like and
can i just make him gay he's like all
right so 50
50. you're gonna hang up upside down
like a bat right
and 50's like yo i don't want to do that
you know i did that for the video right
and i'm also
i'm bigger and i'm bigger and older now
and i have
[ __ ] up knees
no i just think it's just a part of the
the choreography that i set up
because they're going to be dre and
snoop's going to be up there doing their
thing
hang upside down and i'm sure he just
did it it was like i
i guess just happy to be here right and
then
once he was up there during show time
like i just i think imagine the
adrenaline that happens yeah
you know it's like oh god we got to get
this ev the world is watching
and i'm sure he's upside down and it's
like i'm sure he watched it afterwards
and he was just like oh [ __ ] yeah i
didn't consider that the shame he might
have felt or embarrassment would you
think
i thought maybe he celebrated the fact
that he didn't slip off those bars
good yeah maybe
but i thought i didn't he didn't bother
me i thought he was you know i wasn't
you know about a birthday party i don't
know what he's singing about but
i never knew that but it's like i don't
care if it's your birthday
it's my birthday yeah yeah yeah it is
i mean when you're rapping about your
birthday at someone's birthday party i
don't give a [ __ ] it's like it's talk
about the streets
it's your birthday you're 26. here's a
present it's your birthday your
grandma's here yeah i mean like i don't
want to hear about it wait do we have
more questions for urban bob there we go
name three death row rappers
snoop
dre tupac where do you have all the
answers yeah i'll pull up right here
okay
am i right yes you're correct all right
there's actually a lot
name three members of nwa i'm just doing
it yeah i know but you bze
ice cube dre
um i mean those are the main ones okay
go ahead name four members of wu tang oh
yeah old dirty bastard
method man
red man
no
method man you said rizza rizza method
man why four [ __ ] you three there's a
lot of them is why
there's nine of them i know something
with a face thank george kimmel
oh
i don't know
ghost face boo
ghost face killer gary ghost face killer
it's ghost face killer i don't know and
then i i've never heard of ghost face
okay so you didn't get the four members
of wu tang name three female rappers
from the 90s
little kim
nice queen latifah
and money love here we go name one
member from the tribe called quest q-tip
there we go
oh my god congratulations urban bobby
but i'm gonna know more next week
and i'm gonna know the more the week
before because i'm now diving into the
the albums you know
i'm driving into the work
i'm deriving into the um the lyrics i'm
driving into the soul and
the street mentality you know um i know
i grew up with country clubs
you know i know i grew up with trees
uh-huh yeah i know i grew up with you
know
just listen schwinn let's go chewing
bikes yep i knew i grew up with uh
new balance yeah but talk about the pain
the pain oh the pain was tough man
it's like bro growing up dude it's like
i'd be like i don't want kimchi jjigae
you mean i want galbi some or whatever
right yeah i want oxtail soup mom right
she said no you